hello everyone I wasn't going to show a
Carlson game today but I found out that
it was Magnus birthday and decided to
show you one fun game and now Carlson is
the highest rated chess player in the
world and he has been the highest rated
player since June 2011
so he's been highest-rated for over six
years now and the highest rating he
achieved ever was twenty eight hundred
and eighty to elope points so he almost
broke to 2900 record and although I
don't think anything can really come
close to the birthday present Carlson
got last year last year on Carlson's
birthday he was successful in defending
his title a world championship title
against Sergey kurakin and I watched
that press conference and you know there
was pure joy in his eyes but coming to
this game this game was played in 2016
it was the speed chess championship and
chess calm Carlson has the black pieces
against Alexander Greece Chuck and at
the time this game was played a Greece
chuck was still the world with champion
so he was definitely in shape you know
to play a blitz game or two and as the
match took off
Grichuk won the first two games this is
Game three and you know Carlson
definitely needs at least a draught to
break restric streak so let's see how
this game goes d4 by Greece Chuck we
have Knight to f6 c4 e6 and the grecian
goes for Knight to f3 this is the
antonyms of Indian
Bishop to b4 check the bolo Indian
defense night the d2 this is the groom
fault variation Carson castles and a3
now Bishop goes back to e7 e for b6
Bishop to b2 Knight B to d7 and Queen to
c2 now II five by Carlson and nice to be
one Greece Chuck realizes that the
knight isn't really doing anything
useful here and nor has it any good
square to go to so he will play Knight
to be one and then Riemann over at the C
3 and here Carlson definitely has a
couple of good options you can play Ek
her son before he can develop the rook
rook e8 he can play b6 and prepare
Bishop to b7 but he plays c5 and the
district will take advantage of this in
a beautiful way
probably most players would push d5 here
and the d5 isn't a bad move as it will
you know grab a lot of space in the
center he will control c6 he will
control east 6 and it's definitely a
good move but the district decides to go
for something else
he plays D captures on e5 we have night
captors on e5 Knight captures D captures
on e5 and now Knight to c3 and as you
can see because Carlsen pushed c5 and E
5 Carson no longer has any pawns that
control the d5 square and when Grisha
finally decides to play Knight to d5
there is no pawn Carson has that can
kick it away from there so Carson
realizes this and plays Bishop to e6
preparing to give up the bishop at any
point Grisha plays Knight to d5
we have castles by Christian and queen
to c7 and Griffin goes for it
Bishop to e3 adding pressure to the c5
pawn rook F to D it now and now Knight
to d5 Carson of course immediately
captures this monster Knight Bishop
captures but he does have to give up the
bishop pair for it
see captor Sundy 5 and now you have a
protected passed pawn and this is very
uncomfortable for for coulson rook 8 to
c8 rook a to c1
now both players have awoken the Queen
and the C file and there it's very hard
to find a plan for Carlsen here
Grichuk is really piling up on this e5
pawn and if you want to defend it with a
move like b6 then you get Bishop a6
attacking the rook rook moves and after
f3 will have so so much space here that
he controls and it will just be an
easier game for him for a world blitz
champion that's I'm pretty sure that's
enough for a win so after rook a to C 1
cos and decided to play Knight to e8
which is a good idea the night is coming
to d6 from there he will also pressure
efore
see for but this allows a grease chip to
win upon immediately Bishop to g4 now
attacking the rook and there is no way
to block this Carlson has to move the
rook rugby 8 and our gray strip simply
captures the pawn Bishop captures on c5
and a lot of players would probably play
Bishop captures on c5 here leaving the
Queen's on the board as you are down
upon but not Carlson Carlson plays Queen
captures an unbeaten c5 and he goes
straight into the endgame being a pawn
down Queen captures Bishop captures and
rook captures Knight to d6 okay cross
and it does have this beautiful square
for the knight now threatening efore f3
by glistrup and now if you look at this
position grease chip is upper born he's
preparing to play rook F 2 c1 doubling
up on the C file and this Bishop on g4
is controlling c8 so Carlsen can never
contest very strict for the C file so
being up upon and being in such a better
position this is completely winning for
a gray strip so that it should be only a
matter of time before he gets his third
win in the match g6 by Carlsen preparing
moves like f5 or maybe h5 depending on
what good is took place h4 we had f5 e
characters on a5 g characters on f5 and
Bishop to h3 rook to d7 by Carlson and
now g4 and now definitely a good move by
Carlsen King to f7 his idea is that if
Greece should captures on FA on f5 he
will simply play King to have six
blocking it grease chip does play this
he plays G captures on f5 and came to f6
by Carlsen so Carlson sacrificed
another pawn ok he blundered the first
one but he sacrificed the second one so
he's down two points but in exchange he
doubled up districts F pawn and now this
Bishop punish 3 isn't really doing
anything here so it's like a small
victory for Carlson grease chuck is
being very annoyed here King to have two
we have a rogue beat
eight and the cousin plan is at some
point you would like to capture this
pawn with the night and then the double
Brooks will capture the d5 pawn so if he
is able to pull this off it's probably
he'll probably able to draw the game
King to e3 by Greece Chuck wrote the g7
now that the King left the Kings side
the rook will try to infiltrate but
glistrup doesn't mind this he plays h5
Crossan goes immediately with rook to g3
and it's a kind of funny Richard
immediately played Bishop to g4 trapping
the rook and I was watching this game
live and Daniel wrench said that why is
the cost and allowing grease chip to
capture his rook he's already losing two
to zero and you know this King is coming
to have to the rope is trapped but then
they realized what was going on
rook the g8 by Carlson and Greece Chuck
didn't understand what was going on and
Richard did play King to f2 attacking
the rook and it definitely seems like
Carson's rock is trapped
but Carson was so played so happy when
he saw this King to have to move that he
he played rook captures on g4 and when
he played the rook captures on g4 here I
prepared a photo of this moment this is
the photo of this moment you can see him
there very happy you know sticking his
tongue out and laughing and the grief
shook here is very sad and you know it's
like it's like someone it's like a scene
from a horror movie very you know
winning 2-0 to 2-0 against the world
champion and then and then blundering
like this it's chess you know things
happen
okay so now that we've seen that and one
other thing Carson was so happy here and
he didn't even bother to play the
strongest move that is rook eight
captures on g4 because now after F
captures on g4 and Knight to e4 check
you're defending your own rook you're
attacking the rook on c5 so Grisha would
have to move and now Knight captures
rook on c5 and you have
very strong rockin g3 you know you're
you're gonna grab this point you can
play rugby three grab grab the b2 point
you can do anything this is completely
winning like very quickly but Carson was
obviously so happy he didn't even bother
to play it he played rook three captures
in g4f characters on g4 and Knight to e4
check King f3 Knight captures on c5 and
one of the differences now we have the
rook and g8 instead of a rockin g3 and
now this King is already defending the
g4 pawn but okay rook to see one
district well we'll try something as he
does have a I think he's up two points
so he will try something and that b3
attacking the rook rook d7 Knight d4
check King F - King ruck actress Angie
for rook captures on h7 roped for check
King he one king he won and now now e4
Michaelson and this is the famous night
phone rock formation that you can use to
checkmate your opponent in the endgame
these six rook captures on f5 now h6
district is trying to push those past
bonds III now d7 rook to d5 you can't
really play something like rock h5 to
threaten checkmate with rock h1 because
the white will grab a queen with temple
with check so room d5 stopping the pawn
now Ruby g7 not f5 attacking the rook
now degree she promotes the queen with
check rook captures and now rook
captures on b7 Knight captures on h6
rook captures an a7 and now Knight to f5
and here Greece took finally resigned
the game as it simply I mean it's too
simple to win this with the black pieces
I'll just show one line for example
before if he were to push his passed
pawns and then rub the d2
completely cutting away the king from
the game and after a couple of checks
for example Roque 894 now the night is
threatening to come to f3 and also to c2
with check and like I said after a
couple of checks the rook will have to
move and now comes night to see to check
King casts the move and E to check
Carson is promoting to a queen this is
this comes with check from the rook and
Duke is getting check mated in a couple
of moves so yeah that's the game like I
said today is call since 27th birthday
so I thought it'd be nice to show a game
by the reigning world champion so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank an unknown person
Nelson grown ves and Aquila Mendel
Jacobs and Landry the Queiroz Vienna
Braga for a contribution to my channel
and the Landrieu said he only
contributed because of my comment the
chest threesome so thanks sir I'm I'm
glad you enjoyed that so yeah as usual
you can check to all my previous videos
here think all for watching and I will
see you soon